[Musique]
au milieu du programme officiel de la
ministre d outre-mer des rencontres plus
officieuse permettent de faire avancer
des dossiers réunionnais
après le temps du protocole en l'honneur
de sept ministres et nyonnaise vient le
temps du travail des dossiers
les fonctions l'élection les projets
dans cet entretien bien sûr très
important parce que quels sont les
dossiers que justement vous avez abordé
ce que vous peut le savoir vous n'allez
pas le savoir mais c'est un entretien
que nous avons eu constructif avec avec
la présidente avec beaucoup de plaisir
et d'utilité
[Rires]
représentait le gouvernement nécessite
bien des réserves mais cette rencontre
informelle reste essentiel pour l'avenir
on a la chance d'avoir notre ministre
outre-mer qui vient chez elle et chez
nous à la réunion oui c'est important
d'abord d'échangés de voir aussi
l'avancé au fond des dossiers que nous
avons en commun l'avion interpellé
madame la ministre sur des dossiers avec
des réponses à court terme sur les
contrats aidés nous avons obtenu donc
elle quotas supplémentaires des dossiers
qui exige également d'avoir peut-être le
coup de pouce à du ministère de
l'outre-mer on a le sommet de la
francophonie
lescar en parler à la maison d outre-mer
faire en sorte que nous puissions avoir
des délégations avec des associations
qui accompagnent et ben c'est aussi ça
le relationnel qu'il faut et puis il y a
bien évidemment la loi sur l'égalité
réelle avec un contenu qui concerne
également le département de la réunion
sur l'accompagnement des familles le
complément familial mais d'autres enjeux
également économique on a parlé de la
réhabilitation de l'habitat par exemple
à la réunion il ya problématique du
logement on a aussi parlé de comment
mettre en place les conditions de la
croissance pour créer de l'activité et
donc de l'emploi en faveur de la
jeunesse et des moins jeunes à la
réunion
[Musique]